so um the title actually has a
inequality in it it's the power of
community amuk is bigger than a tech
digital textbook and that's what I'm
going to try to argue and uh I'm a
physicist a Duke I'm not an specialist
in education none of what I say is
databased I didn't or have not yet
undertaken any serious study um but for
what it's worth I've been teaching for
20 years and I really like teaching and
so when I was offered the opportunity to
teach auk I hesitated a lot because the
reason I like teaching is because I
think there's this really great
connection you can form with students
and I didn't imagine that the platform
would support it what I want to argue is
a that it does and B that I don't think
we're paying enough attention to that
aspect um so I'm going to go ignore most
of what's in the slides because you all
know all these things um but the the
thesis I want to state is we heard this
this morning learning is hard you want
students to put in a lot of effort and
all the stuff in green is taken from the
discussion forums for one of the Mooks I
taught in astronomy and it people
describing you know losing their
families for this it's hard work the
question is how do you get students to
put in the effort that you want them to
put in in order to make them learn and
at in my anecdotal experience moo and
otherwise the only way to do that is to
get a social interaction going the thing
that motivates people I don't know I
don't think it's money I think it's
social interaction is how we work and so
the the challenge in muks is I think to
systematize what anecdotally I figured
out uh is how to get a a community or a
social interaction going and the point
and that I think is being a little bit
uh ignored is the fact that in auk you
have a community of students there's a
large diverse uh bunch of students doing
the same work and they can collaborate
um and this commity Community
interaction can be an essential part of
learning uh what you can generate is a
situation where the students Bond
there's a a true group uh work going on
both with the instructor and with the
students and I assert that in some sense
auk has an advantage over a college
class having taught both because on the
Forum discussion forums of amuk there's
a sort of relative uh controlled level
of anonymity a student can be as
familiar or as unfamiliar to the peers
as they want to be and uh this allows
people to be very free about I don't get
this can you help me can you understand
and I think that this is the way that
auk is not a textbook in brief what do I
think that other the things we did
facilitated this one is in contrary to
what everybody here has been saying the
homework assignments were open-ended
although quantitative and very difficult
they took hours to complete they forced
students to collaborate we spent a lot
of time being part of the class uh about
2,000 Forum posts by the staff in the
first iteration we did things like
Google Hangout so that they saw each
other's faces and our own and I think
that thinking about how to and we very
carefully designed the forums to keep
the students On Target and I think that
thinking in those directions uh can make
a qualitative difference in how much you
you and your students get out of the moo
it also as an anecdote makes it a lot
more rewarding to teach auk if you're
not thinking that you're writing a
textbook thank you
well we might come back to Jackie
then
hi my name is jio I'm from har x uh my
topic is formative development how do we
improve the course every week so a
little background information about the
course I'm running China X is a mook
about China's history offered by har X
it's a series of 10 many courses and
Each of which last for four to eight
weeks so alt together we have 50 weeks
of conters and this course last from
2013 to 2015 and we are very fortunate
to be able to experiment a a lot of
different pedagogies and Technologies in
this course so it will be extremely
crucial for us to know which works well
which doesn't work well so we can decide
what what will happen in the next week
and we launched the course every
Thursday in the following Wednesday we
release an office hours video so the
professors can talk to students what
happened in the past week and what we
happen in the next
week so in order to quickly apply what
we there doing the past week we need to
do a quick analysis within a couple of
days we'll look at certain metrics like
the participation in performance the
number of active Learners and their
assessment results we also create an
invited environment for them to give us
their feedbacks we have course and
Survey weekly survey we ask them very
specific questions about their feelings
about each component of the course we
also um use different approaches to
analyze them we use work Cloud we use
topic modeling to analyze those kind of
data and we also give them the
opportunity to make decisions we ask
them do you want to watch har college
students to discuss the same questions
if you want we can include them do you
want to hear this guest Professor again
if you want we can invite them back
something like that so they felt they
kind of have an ownership of this course
besides that we also have other feedback
channels like email social media and
other discussion forums so after we make
the decision in a quick fashion we
announc done in the office hours very
explicitly what works well what doesn't
work that well what we will do in the
future we also tell them in the week the
email in social media Etc so after we
change the strategy we will compare the
new week with the past week to see
whether there's any Improvement or not
because of the quick the short time so
we have to make every decision in
analysis analysis very quickly so that's
the gist of this kind of development
thank
you where's my slide okay I'm Jeff
chalen um professor of computer science
at uh University of Buffalo and this is
a collaboration with Margo Seltzer his
way in the back from Harvard um and I'm
here because I've been using Muk type
Technologies in my own classroom to
solve some problems I'm not an
educational expert I'm a domain
scientist um but I'm also here uh with a
with a warning about sort of how mukes
are perceived at other institutions
right so if you're at Harvard or a Duke
right here is what mukes seem like to
you right like this is the future of
this exalted uh you know new world that
we're all going to be living in uh
unfortunately if you're at a middle tier
institution much less you know a lower
tier institution Community College
sometimes mukes look a little bit more
like this right and I don't know if you
can see on this picture but if you look
really carefully there's San J state
right um and so I this is this is a
reality and the question is what are
people afraid of right and I think to
some degree what people like me and
people at other universities are afraid
of is what I'm going to call the single
authored syndication model of how muks
are going to be distributed in the
future right so in this model there uh
there's a course developed at top tier
school if you look at the edex
contributors they're almost all drawn
from Top 100 universities in fact
they're all drawn from Top 100
universities and colleges um so it's
developed by by a single person I just
looked I didn't get through all 200 a
sces but of my sample about uh 87% of
them had one staff person so they're
really being disolved by a single person
here it's Margo who's a fantastic
teacher by the way she taught me
operating systems so not not a bad
person to do it but then this course is
now replicated at a bunch of other
institutions right where people like me
essentially become almost a glorified ta
right I show up I hit play right and I'm
in charge of sort of you know proctoring
the exams and making sure nobody cheats
and Grading homework and things like
this right but I don't have a lot of
ability to contribute to the content or
to modify to meet my needs right and
even if you like the sort of app you
know the the you know Apple I can't say
the word anyway if you even even like
the future of universities that this
model would sort of produce there's some
questions about how effective it would
be for learning right so the two
questions are prompted by uh problems
with you know this sort of model right
the one is you know etex you know
advertises this as Great Courses by the
world's best universities but what are
these universities the best at right I'm
at a research one University that's not
top tier and I still get very very
little reinforcement about teaching it's
almost all research and I think that's
even more true at places like Harvard
and MIT right so are these people the
best teachers in the country could we uh
work together and do a better job the
second thing is that the students at
these schools are obviously not like the
students everywhere else right I see
Harvard students is sort of like the
special forces of learning right you
drop them into a course with very little
support and they will do the job and get
it done and and that's just how they are
right they're really really good at it
so anything that works at Harvard it's
not necessarily going to work for my
students right so I'm almost out of time
but let me try to tell you what we're
trying to do we're trying to build a
collaborative moo platform that would
enable multiple collaborators to
contribute a lot of content into the
system that would be mostly overlapping
at first because we all have our own
courses uh we want this to be deployed
at multiple different kinds of
Institutions and we want over time to
engage a growing community of other
instructors at other places who are
teaching similar courses um eventually
what's kind of cool about this is that
we can specialize people can focus on
things that they're good at I can focus
on teaching the parts of the class that
I'm good at like maybe one or two things
and Margo can teach other stuff um and
so this is the goal of our approach and
our idea is to use modularity thank
you you may need to help me because I am
so there we go all right um I'm not
going to be able to see you which is
probably better um so hi I'm Ann from
novoed I
novoed is a startup out of Stanford um
that it focuses on team building and
social collaboration it's a social
learning platform um my personal history
I was at corsera in 2012 when we had
four partners and before that I taught
at Stanford's online high school and
before that Stanford's education program
for gifted youth so I've been around the
block um what I'm going to talk about
today is uh a series of courses a survey
I did of eight different courses and the
engagement rates that were we're seeing
um so just there's an article about it
that you can look at um first thing how
do we Define engagement so the idea of
Engagement of everyone registering for a
course over or under the number of
people who completed it seems kind of
ludicrous so what we do is we measure
people who admit themselves to the
course by completing the first
assignment that's the denominator over
that we put the numerator of people who
complete rigorous grading criteria now
most of the assignments on our platform
are open-ended they're peer-reviewed and
so I surveyed eight courses that had
engagement rates between 33 and 63% so
33 to
63% of people who completed their first
assignment finished and got a statement
of completion as set out by uh
instructors mostly from Elite
institutions the courses were in topics
like creativity design thinking
entrepreneurship one and two decision
quality we had a course in Spanish on uh
strategic decisionmaking mobile health
and developmental math which was
deployed um is going to be moved into
Community College classroom soon um I'm
sure we'll have lots to talk about there
are um many elements uh that go into uh
these the commonalities for engagement
um they fall into three buckets uh one
is multiple opportunities for
collaboration so teamwork team projects
team work space sending students back
into other students work so all student
work is visible on the platform when the
assignment submission stops everybody
sees everything we send them back have
them comment on things um cohesion of
Project based assignments you look at
the assignment list a student sees that
the steps assignment one builds into
Assignment two the final project is
something that's valuable to them as a
real world context Project based
learning and then three formation of a
learning community so these two help
these other two elements help with that
we also talk about instructor presence
profiles we have active student profiles
that reflect Student Activity in the
class it's not just their bio it's how
many peer reviews they've done what's
been recognized as helpful whether their
foreign posts have been voted up they
have a reputation score their uh
assignments are visible on their profile
these all go into formation of a
learning community we're seeing this
across disciplines and consistently
replicated even as we repeat these
classes and the instructor is much less
involved we see the focus really going
to the students and they're becoming the
engine that make these classes move
forward and if you'd like to read more
about it there's a paper um right there
thank
you hi good afternoon I am Kevin Lynch
from Colgate University um last summer
we started uh looking into mukes and
trying to understand and if there was a
role for mukes in a small liberal arts
Residential College and we decided the
best way to find out was just to go for
it so uh in November we downloaded open
ATX in December we started putting
content up there the first week of
January we recorded get this 20 hours of
video we learned now that that was too
much but live and learn um and we did
this for a course called the Advent of
the atomic bomb this is part of part of
our core program at Colgate which is
really signature to our uh University um
scientific perspective so this course
looked at the development of the atomic
weapon and the historical context around
that um it's co-taught by Professor
Karen harp who's a geologist and uh
Colonel Willie who is a chief dosen at
the Aaron Space Museum brings a lot of
knowledge actually help the anol gay
restoration project so we did these
video lectures and then one of the goals
we want to do with this course is um
Karen is very concerned that 1920 21 Old
students don't have a lot of perspective
on the Cold War on nuclear development
so how can we bring alumni in to help
form inform their perspectives so what
we did is we launched um open ATX as a
private course but we marketed it to our
lumni we got about 500 alumni who agreed
to participate and we put it out there
is help us experiment with this
technology and see where it fits into
the type of education that Colgate
provides um and and the alumni were very
eager to do that so we used a variety of
things we did a um a Twitter play where
over the course of five weeks we act we
had the five years of World War III we
had alumni and students played different
historical characters and they really
got into it some of the students in fact
one of the students continued to tweet
in character up through graduation so
graduation morning was still Tweeting in
character about the uh the events of the
war um we did discussion boards and as
you can see it's kind of hard to see on
the slide but conversations between
alumni and students were inter Le so the
students 24 of them were in a regular
credit bearing class and then these 500
alumni took this online course but they
were completely fused together hence we
call a fusion course because couldn't
think of a different name for it we did
a crowdsource timeline um we weren't
sure how effective that was going to be
we have over 400 entries on that and
it's it's it's amazing the the depth of
detail that was put on there and that
was done with a simple Google form so it
was really easy for students at alumni
to put items on that um and again open
edex powered it all so there wasn't a
huge investment on our part really was
about time we used resources we already
had on hand um what we learned from it
was our older Lums were much more
engaged in the forms which we were
surprised we thought it would be the
younger alums but it turns out a lot of
the younger alums took the course
because they weren't able to while they
were at Colgate the course has been
offered for about 10 years um and just
giving idea with the 24 students there's
40 on the waight list so it's a very
popular course so we finding a lot of
alums this is an opportunity and that's
really key because young alumni is a
tough group to engage and this is a
great way to engage our young alumni and
keep them tied in and I'd be glad to
answer any more questions on it
thanks
Jackie
I was sitting in another session and I
realized iOS to okay I got your slide
here
somewhere okay you just pass okay so in
this presentation we're assuming that
the variables on the right are should be
raised should be increased we're also
assuming that participation retention
and completion actually contribute to
learning that probably hasn't been
proved um and the methodology that we're
experimenting with at Open Doors group
is to ask the participants either as
individuals as small teams or as the
entire class to produce something of
value a service or a product or an
object and preferably something with
some commercial value we're also
assuming or at least hoping that
organizations like open doors group and
similar ones with no taxes and no grants
can actually produce affordable mukes uh
without with and and do it without
having to all of us mortgage our houses
okay um so we are we have three
experiments two we've done one we're
planning the first experiment was two
small mukes that we created in late 2013
last year the first was called rapid
book publishing for educators it
attracted 800 people the second one was
called project management skills for all
careers we sold it out at 2000 students
both were free courses on canvas.net in
the rapid book publish in course all 800
students as a group chose a topic wrote
a book and published it during the four
weeks and in the project management
class there was nothing produced so in a
way it was a control group the things
that were similar they were both free
courses on canvas.net the average or the
most common education level was a
master's degree but there were a lot of
other demographic differences and of
course the subject was different which
could have contributed to the results
and the results were that participation
retention and completion were much
higher in the Educators in the book
publishing
course so um we also think from another
experiment that I don't have time to
talk about that small groups are better
than whole class or individual certainly
participation if you mean participating
with other students is higher so we're
switching from canvas which we love to
novoed which we also love because novoed
has these small group
capabilities and so we will have the
jury still out on whether that's going
to work or not but I would be happy to
share the demographics and the results
from the CL from the experiment I
discussed my my email address is jackie.
Hood atop doors group.org thank
you thank you well can we have all of
our panelists uh up here um I got a
couple of things uh out of that that I
might just throw out there to um maybe
start some uh thinking about some
questions and and one is the importance
of uh when designing a Muk to not only
design the content and the structure of
the course but actually design how the
course gets orchestrated when it's run a
number of these presentations were
really about the orchestration of the
course and how that affects the students
um the other thing that I I pulled out
is uh collaborative design U moving away
from the single academic um designing a
course to collaborative teams whether
they be multiple academics or academics
in conjunction with dedicated learning
designers or media people uh or
additional domain
experts so those a couple of things
there any
questions got a couple of microphones
running
around
oh there's one right up
back so my job is to make the people in
the aisle run a lot um and this is sort
of a Shameless plug so um I'm jeffy's
collaborator and I guess I'd be curious
the rest of you who clearly have
experimented in lots of spaces does this
concept of Cooperative Muk development
and collaboration and modularity
actually resonate with anyone does it
sound completely you know impossible I
would be really interested in getting
other people's
reactions
anyone well we've linked
classrooms and um and and that so that's
linking students it's not quite I think
what you're you're thinking about
because you're going to have different
teachers adding content but but we we've
done that we've had Partners who've done
that where they've linked classrooms in
different countries specifically one in
China and one in the US um and so each
had their own instructor but then the
students worked on shared projects um
and uh and and it worked but it worked
in part because the students can form
their own community and see each other
and see their activity within the
environment yeah I would say we're um
actually working on a course for this
spring um potentially on the edex
platform but we're not positive yet uh
we have a professor at Colgate and a
professor at St Lawrence who both teach
course on the Vietnam War uh the
professor Colgate takes it for a
political
and the professor at St Lawrence takes
it more from a sociological perspective
and um we're going to bring those two
classes together via a Muk like thing
but that idea kind of two different
perspectives on the same event from two
different faculty two different campuses
and we're going to build it and that's
actually being funded by teagle so we're
excited about
that so I haven't done any of these
collaborations but I did sort of try to
to play the role of the second picture
in the the beautiful uh talk there by
having finished teaching AO I sort of
had a friend who was running auk and I
sort of played the TA at Duke and
uh I learned a lot from that and and you
know two string theorists teaching a
physics class is a lot of ego I I think
that modularity and collaboration are
are probably the way this is going to
work and uh I think that that in in view
of the from yesterday a lot of really
open platform open source classes rather
than if we manage to get away from these
closed platforms will basically make
that happen because people will take and
modify and that'll make it a natural
sort of evolutionary thing and I think
that's what's going to happen I
hope uh so for China X we have more than
20 uh guest professors so we try to give
Learners different perspectives by
letting multiple professors talking
about the same topic another thing about
unique thing about China X is we have
large amount of Learners in China we
have uh 6,000 Learners from China so
there's a big language barriers for them
to understand the course so we have a
lot of China Chinese local Partners they
help us translate the course into
Chinese they put the videos into China
because YouTube was banned there and
they did a lot of localization they form
offly discussion groups something like
that so we try to cater to different
kind kind of Learners in different
conditions so my own experience at uqx
out of our first eight courses we've
only had one course it's been a single
academic course um and also the process
that we kind of force our course teams
to go through includes collaborative
workshops where the the the course
streams that are the courses that are
being prepared in parallel which are
from totally different uh domains um are
in the workshop together and they have
to critique their own each other's
designs and we've actually had very good
feedback from the uh course teams that
this kind of collaborative uh critiquing
and uh comparing what other people are
planning to do in their mukes really
helps
them so next question Doug Fischer
Vanderbilt University so I was going to
ask the question that I think was asked
about modularity and get more into it
but as someone who's used mukes in my on
campus courses for since I don't know
couple years two and a half years now um
you know teaching collaborations are
probably the most exciting thing to me
about this space for 25 years I was a
lone wolf when I walked into my class it
was just me and it was very unlike the
research environment which was very
collaborative and Community oriented so
I'm pretty excited about hearing about
some of those plans I guess I would ask
more generally about other possibilities
for teaching
collaborations and I think as a as
something we should measure um is
instructor outcomes as well as student
outcomes and one instructor outcome that
I think is pretty common is if you are
using the content of others you start
creating content yourself and um that is
not part of the the research agenda I've
heard about so I'd be curious to know
those of us that have used the content
of others how often uh do you actually
create your own content to specialize
your course in some way or have you at
least thought about it and is that an
outcome are there other outcomes we
ought to measure of instruction who are
doing this kind of
thing yeah so I think that at least for
me I mean part of my interest in the
space came out of actually trying to you
know so uh the the reason I'm a computer
scien is is really because I took
Margo's class when I was at Harvard
right and so when I started at UB I was
very excited about trying to teach that
class there and it was just impossible
though in its present form right I mean
it's way you know Margot would have I
don't know I'm probably they going to
exaggerate slightly but like four or
five teaching assistants for a class of
maybe 30 students right you know I walk
in on the first day I've got 100
students and two teaching assistants
that have no idea what they're doing
right and so sort of dealing with with
that sort of forced me to develop a lot
of the automation tools that people have
thought about right but I think what I I
find exciting about the idea of
collaboration too and I tried to get out
I I was rushing you know quite badly at
the end of the talk is this idea that
that once you build some trust and once
you build a group of people that are
willing to use each other's content and
and first of all that also provides a
way to evaluate your own your own
modules your own content right how
effectively do I teach something right I
don't know my students don't know right
because they're stuck with me and they
have no alternative right but if they
could watch you know both me and then
Margo and then several other people
explain the same idea right and then we
can look Downstream and see how they do
on an assessment that follows that then
we have some hard data about who's who's
working right and then don't have to
watch me Teach that thing anymore
because clearly I'm terrible at it right
or but the nice thing is over time that
also allows the instructors that are
involved to stop having to curate an
entire course right and try to
contribute either new content try to
improve parts of the class that aren't
working right so I think you know your
idea of a research collaboration is is a
great model right um but I would also
point out that I think that like a lot
of research collaborations one thing
that worries me a little bit about the
book movement is this obsession with
massive scaling these massive platforms
and abused all over the place right the
most research collaboration occurs
between a handful of people right who
are really focused on one particular
problem there's you know trust there's
relationships that are built up right
it's not this big Anonymous thing where
I go online and I download of course
from someone I've never met and don't
know anything about right and really
don't have any way to contribute to
either
so so our classes are are created by a
lot of people at the same time um I was
really impressed there's a no class out
of State University of New York that was
had 17 instructors I thought just doing
that was an exercise and in some kind of
brilliant coordination but we typically
have about 10 or 12 people and because
we're we're Advocates of open
educational resources we started in the
project management course with a book by
Mary Baron and Andrew Baron at Rice
University called project management for
in scientists and Engineers we wanted we
had to tailor it to have people
understand that business owners ERS and
teachers and nurses and other people
also use project management skills in
their career so we added a whole first
section and Mary Baron came back and
said gosh I wish I'd thought of having
this section you have on Intercultural
communication that we added to the book
and then we of course republished the
book and so on so I think if you have if
you have an oar mindset you're going to
be able to farm the the Oar that's out
there on connections and other sources
and then you will feel an OB obligation
to put back in there as
well hi so my name is Ed cutel and I
work for Microsoft research in Bangalore
in India and some of the stuff that
we're working on is trying to see how we
can use online resources in sort of
fourth tier colleges in in India and so
this notion of the smoking ruins um
compared to the gorgeous uh thing is
something that I feel very acutely um
but the notion
of this this Fusion or sort of like
mixing all kinds of different resources
is something that's very important for
us in the way that we work because what
we're doing is something that is
supplemental to existing colleges so the
colleges you're taking a course and then
we're trying to help the fact that the
you know the teachers many cases have
they're just out of college themselves
have no teaching experience and so we're
trying to both Pro provide models but
also something that matches the Cur
curriculum of those colleges and you
can't do that with just taking a course
from edex or course era you really have
to mix and match lots of small little
units in order to appropriately match
that and so I just want to
emphatically uh reinforce this notion of
this kind of model because that seems to
be what's really working for us and I'd
like to to encourage you all to also
think about the ways in which the work
that you're doing can be applied in
those kinds of
contexts
so I I want to mention we um are in the
process of rolling out to about 250
Community College classrooms the
Carnegie foundation for the advancement
teaching math courses the pathways
courses that Susan mentioned the other
morning um and we're running up against
this right so you know how do you not
train because I don't like that word but
how do you help Community College
instructors use uh a a technology that
they can modify because the old
technology ology that was just like
here's the textbook right it's online
and and now they have capability for
modification but we they don't
necessarily know what to do so we're
we're stumbling along in the dark trying
to help them figure out here's what you
can do and I'm just letting you know
that we're working on it and no
conclusions because we're letting them
tell us where to go and more next year
so next year I guess so right another
thing that I've observed that might uh
help with the sharing and reuse is that
uh the the number of short mukes seems
to be increasing as as well so when muks
first started a lot of them were you
know the full 13we semester style
courses but now you're finding a lot of
eight we and even four- we courses
starting to appear and this means that
you know someone could use that just as
a single section of uh another course uh
quite easily yeah I mean I've one I've
loved being at this Workshop because I I
don't know anything about about this
area so I'm finding all this sort of
stuff out and I was just at the a
session talking about an experiment
where some community colleges nearby use
some adex courses that were developed in
M MIT and it was really exciting to hear
that this was happening but the courses
they were given were locked down at x
classes that they weren't allowed to
modify the content of and it was
frustrating because you heard the
instructors talking about a lot of work
that they did to adapt the courses for
their own students right now first of
all you know I think a lot of people
here when they hear that there's this
idea sadly of sort of dumbing down the
material right you know and no no no
that doesn't need to flow upwards to the
MIT class right no way would a Bunker
Hill Community College teacher know how
to teach physics better than an MIT
Professor that's just impossible right
um and I think we need to get away from
that because that's just not true right
but then the fact that they had
conducted this experiment in this weird
way where they had given them this
Frozen version of the class I I find
that very difficult to understand right
it was a great idea right we need to
encourage more collaborations between
institutions that are in different
categories but it just seemed like it
came with a lot of baggage you
know sir uh I have a question for Kevin
I mean it was really nice to hear about
how you're integrating your alumni in
your courses uh can you talk a bit more
about how you manage that interaction
between alumni and student especially if
you have a lot of people contributing to
the message boards and so on is there
some kind of quality control do
interactions get out of hand or was that
not the
case so um so this is the first course
we've done that uh we partnered with our
alumni Affairs office so they did a lot
of the marketing for us as well as a lot
of the um back and forth because some of
our older alumni had some challenges
getting the course signed up and things
like that um we we're actually launching
a course in two weeks here called living
riters online which is a similar thing
where we uh the on campus will review 10
books over the semester but on the uh
edex Edge site we'll do four books and
that's open to alumni friends in the
community so we're going to have a
larger pool there
and um again we're going to just kind of
play it by year and see how it goes I I
we didn't have a lot of issues with that
actually it was a very positive
collaboration to the point we actually
had I believe at least two alumni travel
to campus to sit in on a class which the
instructor was very open to doing so it
you know I kudos to the instructor uh
her and her uh partner there from the
air and space museum were wonderful to
work it took a lot of input and it was a
very team effort um so we haven't seen
that issue yet um that is a concern is
if we open to a true moo and it's the
whole world what is that and that's one
of the reasons that that particular
course hasn't gone public yet um because
it's a very controversial topic another
thing that came up and Karen will be
very honest about that she's not an
expert in atomic we she's a geologist
she teaches this course because it's
part of our core program so she has some
concerns but she's also said that you
know it's helped her be a better
instructor and really look at the
material she uses in those things so and
can you talk a bit more about the
community college and carnegi project
that you just mentioned oh and sure so
um so uh the Carnegie foundation for the
advancement teaching under uh Tony BR
decided to address the community math
college math problem uh it was the cours
Weare was on oi um which was static and
lock down it was gorgeous I I mean I
played around in it to help redesign it
I have all good things to say about it
um they wanted to move to something that
had more flexibility for instructors
they weren't sure what that was um and
so they chose us in part of because of
the social collaborative features in our
initial rollout we're not emphasizing
team building or any of those things
because you you know I I don't know if
any of you have been in the position of
being an instructor where two weeks
before a course starts they or class
starts they go you're using this
technology this
semester translate everything right it
sucks to be that person um and so we're
very sensitive to that you know having
that in mind um what what the focus of
uh my work with them really is is here
are ways to encourage Community using
email forums you know just things that
you don't need to wrap your mind around
virtual team formation online and then
across campuses right we'll get there
but the idea is that because of the Core
Curriculum which involves teaching math
using productive persistent mindset
intervention productive struggle a lot
of peer-to-peer interaction peer work
and um and productive persistence
messaging continual messaging and
encouraging and Improvement Sciences
also data driven science and analytics
we really need flexibility and the
platform allows for that so it allows
for constant iteration and then one uh
just a a a shout out because the data
people will like this um so we're
they're going to get it carne is going
to get a nightly dump of data to analyze
what's happening right and then we're
just it's because it's so customizable
we can we can make adjustments much more
quickly and then they can send out
interventions to various classrooms like
okay you know what everybody's failing X
but that's that's pretty much where we
are any more question yeah yeah this is
a question for China X um so every week
you invite professors to speak for short
segments about China and I was wondering
is there a formula to create engaging
videos that students actually enjoy and
watch the whole thing and you know not
get
bored so can you repeat your question is
there a formula for creating engaging
videos uh yes so we try different types
of videos some video are as long as 40
minutes long some videos are as short as
2 minutes long so we try to CER some
sometimes professors have a storytelling
style sometimes people are just reading
from script so we ask people which one
do you prefer we divide people into
several groups and we ask them which one
do which kind of video do you prefer and
also we have some kind of videos that uh
that us specifically designed for social
media purpose we have one video one one
minute long video it's about Professor
singing a song about Chinese dynasty
that has gone wider in China it has been
watched by four million people in one
week so the professors are over n
celebrities in China now and so we have
different strategies for different kind
of videos and to cater to the styles of
the professors the Conns and their
specific their nurse so in general
though what have you found that um most
feel
like uh people have different tastes but
generally it depends on their conters
and their uh personal style if it's a
very difficult content if the professors
were kind of reading style so it might
be better to have shorter videos if it's
really engaging video it's okay to have
40 minutes
long thank you oh sorry I have another
question um so and you mentioned that
you get uh student feedback every week
and then if they like the professor you
invite them back um but often student
feedback is very broad you know like
critique my teaching style and they're
all like it says something very broad
that you can't apply specific speically
to um how they teach so I was wondering
how you guys uh kind of constructed your
question for student feedbacks to get
the most effective um yeah so we we ask
very specific questions about specific
component of the course like the video
the video l or the the content or the
format of new technologies because we
have uh included a lot of new
technologies in the course like Dynamic
map The annotation tools uh different
tools so each week we when we launch a
new technology we ask them to describe
their learning experience we ask them to
give us uh suggestions and something
like that so we analyze those feedbacks
in different ways and then we decide
whether we want to keep that technology
or not whether we want to reinforce that
learning points or not thank
you I should say that uh one of the
things we've discovered in uqx is that
uh different academics have different
talents in front of a camera um and so
when where designing our our courses now
we're having to you know do screen tests
of the academics first to work out what
sort of videos we're going to use
because some of them require an audience
to to light up some of them you put them
in front of a camera and and you'd think
that they'd work in the TV industry
their whole
life got another question down here in
the
front so this is this is about about
citation and uh we have a a tradition of
citing in research we don't have a
tradition of citing in education so far
as I can tell I know the open movement
is very much into
acknowledgement um should we so that
people in Academia start taking uh the
teaching products that we produce
seriously as as intellectual output um
and because this stuff is public facing
I sense that there is going to be an
increased need to site openly um I'm
waiting for the time when a moo
instructor uses somebody else's homework
exercise doesn't acknowledge and gets
hammered on the discussion forums for
plagiarism um something we want to avoid
should we in the open movement I can
specify how I would like it cited should
we as a group start thinking about
standardizing uh a method of citation
and citing um educational output so that
academics do start taking it seriously
well I I've thought about this um but
based on actually a conversation um a
few almost a year ago now with the
teaching Learning Center at Stanford um
we started doing case studies of courses
and if you go to their teaching Commons
site you can see case studies I started
writing case studies of some of our
mukes and Designs mostly just for
note-taking purposes for myself and then
it became useful because when someone
Professor would come and say Hey I want
to do these kinds of things I could just
send off they're pretty boring but you
know just send off like here are some
case studies that that you talk about
the pedagogical strategies um I bring
those up because they've been useful to
me and I think that if that became some
kind of practice I don't know if that's
something that would be cited but at
least there's a way to kind of track
design change and and um Evolution and
then people can measure
it well we we use standard
bibliographical citation format um
and in our current class when I wrote
the style guide the long ones are
they're too long you go to Chicago
school or something it goes on for pages
and pages I found one called how to
write your term paper that's written for
10th graders and it's simple and it
includes all the standard here's how to
site a book here's how to site a
magazine article journal and here's how
to site internet
content and we also there's a Stanford
guidelines for intellectual property
that we use that talks about how to just
uh site to include links in your class
because as Stanford says it's usually
legal to just jump to a link it may rot
on you and you have to check it every
term but but there's still an etiquette
about it in terms of you should be
citing it with the name of the link not
you know putting up a dumb picture and
then having a link behind it that has
nothing to do with that picture and you
should also site at the top level of the
of the website and then tell people how
to get down to the level that you're
talking about because if that for
example if that website is advertising
supported it's not fair to jump down to
the bottom because then you're killing
the sustainability of that website so so
there's both legal and etiquette and I
think we should observe them just like
people in in publishing
do yeah I mean I I I like the idea of of
attribution I I think the question is
how do we um how do we make it useful
right because I'm I'm not sure that I
really um I think there's something
different about the types of citation
and really it's frequently downlike
plagiarism that people do in their
classes right I mean this is sort of the
classic way that young faculty develop a
new course right which is they don't
right they take their advisor's class
and they copy it right and they copy the
slides they copy the assignments right
um and a lot of times you know the last
slide it'll always say these slides were
originally from here right and and to
some degree you know that that seems
like it's not something that that uh as
academics we're particularly
uncomfortable with what I worry more is
how do we build that into a system that
allows things to change and allows
people to fix mistakes and allows rather
than having a tree where you know
somebody's conceptual mistake about how
to teach a particular concept is now
replicated over and over and over by
every generation of of students and
their students right until you have
whole sort of communities of class
and it's not even teaching something
that's incorrect it's just teaching in a
way that's not very effective right so I
I see licensing sort of to me and I
haven't thought about this more for more
than since you asked the question but it
seems like licensing could be a better
way to go right where the the permission
is given you know at the time that the
content is produced and there are
expectations about how the content is
used and how changes and improvements
are pushed backwards right and are
shared with the community right so when
you write software you don't worry about
citing things you use somebody else's
library because it has a license that
you like and then when they fix things
you also get those updates and things
improve right so I think if we could
take that model and again I'm a computer
scientist so I try to work everything
into my own little mental framework
right because um but I think that that
seems like it's more effective than than
a scholarly citation
model well I we can't talk about this it
seems without veering into the the p
word which is publishing right in
textbook which you guys have you know
talked about and so I guess that's my uh
one of the cautionary point points that
I see with um citation right is that are
we just as there there are lousy
textbooks that have done you know years
of damage you know do we want to
copyright or or uh courses that aren't
you know in three years as Technologies
and and the digital literacy of students
and education you know backgrounds of
students change and who we're reaching
also don't work that
well so in community colleges we're
really trying to encourage departments
to develop courses and textbooks because
um and we use a lot of adjuncts and
adjuncts are brought in often at the
last minute as as Anne was mentioning
and we've actually had one instance
where Professor got sick went ontical
something and the adjunct was brought in
a few days before the course and the
professor tried to charge the adjunct to
use his materials and and we just need a
more Cooperative approach and there are
some really good textbooks out there
that were written by particularly the
College of the Redwoods some math
textbooks so we want to see this and we
had an interesting experiment or look at
statistics in the humanities the
individual Professor or instructor
chooses the textbooks in The Sciences
it's more often the department and in
business it's the college because
business professors are almost always
from industry and they come in and they
don't have time to develop material so
they take the material that the college
provides um also uh it might be really
nice if a moo platform provided a way
for contributions like uh additional
quiz questions and things like that uh
so that a course could be improved over
time I don't don't know if any of the
platform oh you do
excellent any more questions up
there so I had another one um I would
point out that licensing goes hand inand
with acknowledgement or citation uh
creative Commons every license requires
acknowledgement um but the other
question was on what I think the fusion
model is which is a local
group doing a moo in conjunction with a
Global Group is that correct um could
you elaborate on that because that's a
very different model than the closed
instance um you have the opportunity for
local students to benefit from that
Global cohort and I'm wondering if you
could tell us about more lessons that
were learned there whether the other
have experience in that area as well
yeah so um you know it wasn't truly GL
it was Global but it was still
restricted to um Colgate alumni in this
case the next iteration will be a little
bit broader and then we'll go full guns
and go for the whole thing um so what we
learned from that it was actually it
accomplished a lot of what we wanted it
brought a lot of diversity of thought
and opinion um but that's also one of
the things that we're cautious of and
actually I think would make a great um
companion move
is how do you talk about significant
events in history that are very
controversial in a global perspective
because it's one thing to talk with a
group of Colgate students and a group of
Colgate Alum about the the events
leading up to dropping the bomb in
hoshima but now if we have um students
in that course from Japan what are their
opinions going to be and how do you have
that conversation in a collegial way I
think that goes to your question about
how do you how do you control a
discussion group because it could get
very cont versal so we're still learning
that and and working with our faculty
working with our alumni base we'll work
with our friends hopefully you all we
have but I think it'd be great to have a
separate move just to talk about that
how do you talk about controversial
things when you from a Global
Perspective there's very different views
on that event um I think it'd be
great um so we're uh launching a a Muk
in global history um that that was
offered on corsera it helped with on
corsera and now we're bringing it um
it's global history in the global
classroom and uh the students on campus
are going to be in teams and they're
going to be interacting with these teams
self fored teams of people around the
world discussing um difficult topics and
I'm going to take a lot of
value and we we've got an upcoming
course on anthropology of of current
world issues which will have very
similar sorts of things so uh the moo
platform provides a a very exciting
domain for for exploring uh cultural
issues and and geographical
issues so one of the speakers brought up
this idea that you know when we start
teaching we just copy our advisor
syllabus and something that we have done
before and so on so one of the
expectations you would have from moo is
when do we stop recreating content and
what are the boundaries between just
creating and recreating and actually
doing something different right so do we
see that happening or is just going to
be more and more content keeps getting
produced without any real curation
overall of the
content um so one thing that I've
observed just from the professors that I
work with is that they you know they
enroll in all the other courses and what
they've wanted to do and sometimes do do
is just link to each other's content or
ask you know now this is in intra
institutional right so it's okay usually
but can I you know and I I've sometimes
brokered these deals right so does the
Stanford Med course benefits from the
GSB course and can we do that something
like that so so I see potential for that
model to move where where you know you
say you know what somebody's got the
best lecture on this topic but just that
one little bit but I want to use that
one little bit which goes to your mod
modularity thing yeah I think that's a a
great question and one of the things
we're interested in some of the course
that we're looking at in the humanities
for example living writers that's new
every year because it's a different this
this year it's 10 International authors
next year it'll be 10 different authors
so it's a it's a complete Recreation
each year it's not just the same content
um so that's something that we want to
look at um and then in our core programs
we're also looking at to the same thing
how do we take the best of so we teach
um a course on Antiquities and so we
have a professor who's very
knowledgeable in the Book of Genesis so
instead of having uh a geologist again
who might be teaching that course talk
about it then we could use some of that
content and do that so we're trying to
get that best of readed but I think we
do need to be realistic and to not
offend any of my colleagues at Colgate
we wouldn't offer an engineering course
we don't offer engineering so I won't
offend anybody but because that's
probably done better somewhere else so
what we look at is what do we do at
Colgate that we think we do as well or
if not better but a very Val point I
don't know where you start to kind of
figure the best to breed and and I know
we're supposed to forget about learner
Styles I get that just move on I think
was the comment or Let It Go um but
perhaps there does need to be some
diversity in how it's taught because I
think you know maybe it's not a learner
style but it there's diversity in way
things taught and people may pick it up
differently I wanted to add the session
that I accidentally went to is the group
of people at MIT that are building this
backbone with edex modules at the
assessment level the video level the the
text level and so on for sharing within
MIT so that you're building a Physics
course you can go get the best video on
on spin Theory or something and you can
go get the best assessments on something
else and then they intend to share this
out to the larger edx Community I left
too soon to find out if they're going to
get Beyond using edx um into other
platforms we use a product called Soft
chalk which is really popular among
community colleges and it's a Content
management system that can be deployed
out then to Moodle or Sakai or or novoed
or other tools and it's a better editor
than most of the LMS have can do fancier
things so a Content management system
could really contribute a
lot but I I also I think there's a
dangerous word that's being thrown on up
here which is best right you know I mean
the the best lecture on this the best
explanation of this particular topic I
don't know if that exists right I don't
know if we have any evidence that it
exists really in a way that's meaningful
right I mean if if best is
distinguishing between the one that you
know uh the one that 10% of students can
learn from rather than 8% right
effectively then maybe it doesn't matter
right maybe we're talking about a a real
interesting plurality rather than this
idea of the best right so I think that I
think that I don't know I feel like that
idea has actually just worked its way
into a lot of the design of the moo
platforms that are out there right is
that there's an implicit assumption that
somebody maybe we don't know where that
person is or who they are but someone
gives gives the best explanation of this
particular topic right and I don't know
if I believe that right um and I
certainly think that I haven't seen a
lot of evidence that it's true right and
so I think that you know and you know
think think about it this way what
happens when the best you know person to
explain this topic delivers the
five-minute video and the student
doesn't understand it right what do you
do then do you show them the best person
again right and until they get it um you
know so I think there's there's still
even if you believe in the best right
which again I don't think anyone has any
have any has any evidence for this
there's still this idea that we could
still use more content now I agree with
you about it doesn't have to be a person
content is not a person sure sure you
are you are I'm going back to your I'm
going to go back to your question right
I'm just responding to some of the
things the panelist said right but you
know this idea that should we produce
content at infinitum no right but we
really don't do that I mean my point was
a lot of times faculty don't produce new
content right we're essentially
borrowing and and sealing things from
our advisers and other people we
probably should produce more content but
we also need to deploy content in a way
that allows us to understand what we're
good at producing what's effective what
should we keep and what can we get rid
of and what do we need to fix right like
I wish I could you know have a tool that
would just tell me here is you know I'm
going to teach the same class again next
Spring right I don't have enough time to
rethink my conceptual approach to
teaching the whole class right what
don't I teach well right what are the
you know five lectures that I should
rewrite or the five pieces of various
things that students aren't getting I
don't feel like I really have a tool to
do that and I think some of the modu of
tools that we're trying to develop would
help with that as
well
sorry discussion on the other end well I
I I just so one thing I say when I talk
to professors and if I were talking to
you to help you design your courses I
would say think about it as a meal so
you're creating this house party if it's
a moo it's a house party right you're
creating an experience for student
students now you may want the best beer
and you may want the best porn chips and
you may want the best burritos but
you're creating an experience and that's
the that should be the focus not any one
little
Point yeah I think I wanted to to to
also answer in that a similar vein
because the the content is the part of a
Muk that is a textbook and yeah there's
a finite e ecosystem over which
Publishers have
been the Publishers carve out really
nicely for I don't know what calculus
textbooks but a mukin calculus is not
the same as uh calculus text and just
for the same reason that there have been
I don't know 20 textbooks in calculus
and hundreds of people teaching calculus
classes that are not isomorphic copies
of those textbooks I think there's room
for mukes and I think you know none of
us is going to rewrite Newton calculus
has been there for for a while but
there's room for a lot of different
people teaching calculus in lots of
different ways and I so so I think the
the mo yes there's bigger reaches
there's an issue of how many different
copies of a calculus lecture do we need
but it's not it's somewhere in between
textbooks and because auk is an
experience and if I'm going to interact
actually with a professor who's going to
be writing the homework is going to be
explaining things going to be answering
my questions then I think it's really
valuable that this is the same person
that I watched sort of explain uh
variables change of variables in an
integral because I formed a connection
to that person through having
conversation with him I'll listen to how
he changes variables differently than
I'll listen to Somebody I've never met
the the the former is like a is like a a
course and the latter is just reading a
textbook and I think we can position Muk
somewhere in the middle
there maybe we should start removing
personality from some of the
mukes yeah yeah the the instructor does
does tend to be a very important part uh
I think we're run out of time there
um one more as long as it's one minute
um okay um I just uh just to follow up
on what what was just said I think that
um it's helpful often to think of as
Continuum if you between uh information
uh data information and knowledge and I
think our courses sit we we think that
when students are in our classes that
we're in the knowledge part and I think
that's true um and I think that you
could argue that the the internet or
whatever produces data let's say or a
textbook perhaps produces information
but it's the role of the instructor to
kind of weave it together and help the
students create knowledge in that
classroom experience and I think there's
a place for muks to do that knowledge
cre ation bit but it's how you use the
the information or the data wherever you
want to start from it's
all okay I think we're going to wrap it
up there we're three minutes
over I think we've had a a wonderful
conversation here with some really great
topics thank you to all of the panel for
their presentations and participation
and thank
you
I thought that session
really